il est 22h30 3 ce 14 juillet à nice les
clips panique émane de la foule venue
assister au traditionnel feu d'artifice
pendant plusieurs minutes
un homme fait rouler son camion sur la
promenade des anglais fauchant des
centaines de personnes le chauffeur est
finalement abattu par les forces de
l'ordre
au total 86 personnes sont décédées 450
autres sont blessés au lendemain de
l'attaqué
la promenade est bouclée les niçois
choqué assistent désemparés aux relevés
des enquêteurs
la promenade des anglais rouvre au
surlendemain du drame l'émotion est
toujours très vif
[Musique]
2363 victimes de l'attentât de nice ont
été ou seront indemnisés car au delà des
décès et des blessés l'attaqué a
traumatisé des centaines de personnes
quatre ans après cet attentat l'enquète
s'est achevée c'est le conducteur du
camion un tunisien de 31 ans a été
abattu le soir du drame
neuf autres personnes sont suspectées de
complicité il ya quelques jours le
parquet national anti terroriste a
demandé le renvoi devant la cour
d'assises